PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Does the
security of your applications
keep you awake at night?
Stay tuned to learn
how Anthos can help.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Priyanka, and
welcome to Anthos 101.
Each of your
customers implicitly
trusts you with their
data, and keeping it secure
is your top priority.
In this video, let's
learn more about
how Anthos makes it easier
to secure your applications.
As key technologies like
containers and micro-services
become more commonplace,
traditional security models
are no longer sufficient.
Security posture is
fragmented based on parameters
like your platform-- do you
run on premises, or in cloud,
or both?
Your workloads, are you running
your VMs, or containers,
or both?
Your services are they
regulated or sensitive workloads
or public-facing information?
Some problems with
older methods are
lack of visibility
into what is happening
on your networks,
lack of consistency
in terms of controls
or policies.
Enabling a zero-trust
security posture
can help you solve these
issues and also modernize
your security for hybrid
and multi-cloud deployments.
And Anthos equips you with
all you need to implement
a zero-trust model.
But first, what is zero-trust?
It is a security
principle that is
based on implementing security
controls at every single layer
of your stack and
with every interaction
or engagement, often
considered as defense in depth.
This means you start with secure
bootstrapping at every node
and in every cluster.
Next you secure the
network, not just
at the perimeter and the edge,
but by effectively segmenting
your deployment and securing
the network for each service.
Then you secure access,
be it your infrastructure,
your application, or
the underlying data.
You also secure your
deployments and rollouts
by making sure both your
code and your configuration
are only ruled out when
trusted and validated.
And finally, you can't protect
against what you cannot see,
so you need better observability
to enforce compliance
and quickly spot threats.
Now let's see why you
need these and how Anthos
helps you accomplish these.
First, secure bootstrapping.
This is essential
because any issues here
can quickly affect
multiple services shared
in your infrastructure.
Google Cloud provides you with
features such as shielded VMs,
container optimized OSs to
reduce your risk surface,
and encryption at rest to
prevent unauthorized access.
You also have access
to hardening guides
to help you incorporate
best practices on premises.
Next, let's talk about securing
your network in such a way
that you are protecting
all your diverse workloads.
This is where you can
protect against exfiltration
of your data, either
maliciously or unintentionally,
to uncontrolled environments,
unauthorized access
from the internet using
either stolen credentials
or by exploiting
misconfigurations,
and remote code execution
attack like SSRF.
Google Cloud provides
you with everything
you need to protect both
your public-facing apps
and to seal your
perimeter using products
like Cloud Armor, Anthos GKE
security controls, and VPC
service controls.
It is also essential
to secure access.
This helps you protect against
unauthorized access using
stolen credentials, compromised
code in your deployments
through privileged escalations
or unpatched vulnerabilities,
malicious insiders with
access to internal endpoints,
and any underlying
network compromises.
Anthos helps you implement
these controls using
a combination of features,
such as Anthos Service
Mesh to implement
authentication, authorization,
and encryption
between your services,
and IAP to implement
granular access controls.
We spoke about securing your
deployments and rollouts.
This is essential
to reduce trust
on a single deployer or admin.
Anthos provides you
with capabilities,
such as binary authorization, to
ensure that your workloads are
trusted and validated
before they can make it
into your deployment,
preventing any untrusted code
from running there.
And when it comes to
your configurations,
Anthos Config Management
helps you establish a trusted
workflow, including reviews and
approvals for any configuration
changes that can impact
your deployments.
This way, you can manage
your policy as code.
In addition, monitoring is not
only key to quickly identifying
threats, but also to
maintain detailed audit
logs and records for compliance.
Anthos gives you access
to detailed audit logs
for your code, your
configurations,
and your network.
So today we saw that Anthos
and Google Cloud give you
everything you need to
deploy a zero-trust model
for your applications.
It gives you the ability
to deploy and maintain
a security posture
that is consistent
across in environments, policy
driven, optimized for cloud
native applications, application
and user context-aware.
Try Anthos for yourself, and
get started on your journey
to zero-trust security
following the links below.
And for more Anthos
content, don't
forget to subscribe and follow
the entire Anthos 101 playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]